[Musique]
une exploitation marécher donc
producteur de différents légumes du
légumes d'été tomat concombre courgette
et une production aussi de frais orceel
qui est de fraise précoce après la
fraise on a une production donc tomate
qui est assez développée sur différentes
variétés de variétés anciennes comme
ananas nord de crimécebra on dit
également des tomates rondes classiques
pour régrmenter la gamme et aussi des
tomates cerises en plein champ on a une
production de salade courgette et après
plus ça vaêre pleinchamp qui va être
récolté l'hiver donc la carotte les
courges et les choux bien sûr en chou on
a aussi une gamme de varié qui va du
chou-fleur CHOU
broncoli CHOU pomme
chou rouge et chou Bruxelles l'année
dernière on a fait débuté notre essai
cornichon donc pour pouvoir développer
notre gamme de conserve on a envie de
pouvoir proposer une gamme de conserve
pour qui adapté à toute l'année avec
notamment des ketchups qui qui plaisent
beaucoup et des soupe des plats préparés
du caverre d'aubergine nos cornichons et
aussi confiture de fraise donc on
travaille avec la conserverie à la roche
frigo avec qui on a vraiment un échange
sur les recettes on a nous on choisit la
texture l'assaisonnement le le
conditionnement aussi car c'est une
volonté par exemple pour nos ketshop
d'avoir un conditionnement assez haut et
ça tout ça c'est un travail d'échange
avec eux qui se fait très bien et on
gère plutôt la partie vente avec une
vente directe par semaine sur notre
exploitation donc c'est le jeudi et
après on a un magasin de producteur qui
est ouvert 2 jours et demi par semaine
du vendredi au dimanche matin sur
Richelieu à 20 minutes de l'exploitation
et on travaille après avec des
restaurateurs sur le local des commerces
aussi qui proposent notre gamme de
conserve et des magasins de producteurs
qui sont un petit peu plus sur
Poitier mais on reste toujours sur la
proximité 1 2 3 et n'oubliez pas on est
à de pas chez
[Musique]
vous